cuando Carlos III fue proclamado Rey la
declaración de lealtad al monarca se
escuchó mucho más allá de las costas
británicas
hoy conmemoramos el fallecimiento de la
Reina Isabel II y reconocemos a su hijo
Su Majestad Carlos III como nuestro
soberano
rey de Australia y sus reinos y
territorios jefes de la comuna
larga vida al rey El Monarca británico
también es el jefe de estado en 14
reinos de la mancomunidad de Naciones
fuera del Reino Unido aparte la
asociación voluntaria cuenta con otros
41 miembros incluidos togo y gabón que
se unieron este año a pesar de ser dos
naciones sin vínculos coloniales con
Gran Bretaña la difunta Reina Isabel
supervisó el fin del imperio pero
mantuvo unida a la como Wolf Aunque el
número de reinos se redujo con los años
en 2021 Barbados se convirtió en el
último en romper con la monarquía Aunque
permaneció en el commonwealth en general
a principios de este año cuando el
príncipe William realizó una visita
oficial a Jamaica el Primer Ministro le
dijo que esperaba que el país pronto
abandonará sus lazos con la corona y se
convirtiera en una República la muerte
de la reina Isabel también ha reavivado
el debate en Australia sobre la salida
de la monarquía mediante un tuit en un
homenaje a la difunta soberana un líder
del partido verde dijo ahora Australia
debe avanzar necesitamos convertirnos en
una República Aunque el Primer Ministro
Anthony albanís partidario desde hace
mucho tiempo de que su país se convierta
en una República dijo que este no es el
momento para hablar sobre el tema